Okay, so in our browser I've reloaded the page and let's test
out all that new code we just wrote. Okay, so I added
steak and you can see it reloaded the page food equals steak
in the URL and it added our shopping list. So now you can
see what we've been working towards this whole time. Let's take a
quick view of the source code of this file. So you can
see our form here and you can see we stuck in the
input hidden value equals steak. And then our shopping list that we appended
to the end of that output HTML you see a
list item for steak. Now let's go ahead and try
adding another food, eggs. You can see what's on my
mind this morning. Okay, so you can see we have both
our elements in the URL, that's because, when this page
loaded last time, it had steak as a hidden input, remember,
and when we submit the form, the hidden input stays
preserved. Let's look at the source for this version of the
page now, and you can see we have two inputs
two hidden inputs, one for eggs, and one for steak. And
then we can see, we have the list items, we have
been adding. Notice that the whitespace here, is kind of messed
up. HTML always puts list items unless you install it
otherwise, on their on line. So, independent of whatever white space
is in our source, HTML will display it. let's, let's try,
just for fun, adding something to URL here. How about food
equals pizza and when I hit enter we get pizza
added to our list. let's go through this code one last
time so you can understand fully what just happened. We
got our form HTML's from just a basic form and inside
that form that's where we're adding in the hidden inputs.
If I were to view the source of a version of
this page you would see that we have three hidden inputs
when we have three items, food items in the URL. The
HTML that describes those hidden inputs is here. Now,
in our code, we said that if there were
any items in the URL, any items that come
from the food parameter, that we would do all of
this string formatting here where we basically build up
a list of the hidden items, and then build up
a list of the list items. These bits of
HTML here. And then concatenate everything together, putting the items
into the list and then putting that whole shopping list at the
end of our output, and then, finally, we substitute our hidden html
that we've been building up into our output string and we write
the whole thing back to the user. So, the functionality we get
here is a kind of neat side effect of how storing data in
the url allows us to build this fake shopping list functionality. But,
it was a little bit of a pain to write. Okay, and
now it's time for one of those quizzes where you probably already
know all of the answers. So what is wrong
with that previous solution that we just went through? Check
all that apply. one, it's a pain to change.
Next, we don't get any syntax highlighting in our HTML.
Our code is ugly, and it's very error prone.
And I, I'm, I left out of the video the
part where I was swearing trying to get all
of this working for you. Okay. Check all that apply.